This is I'd like to know, our Biblebased
question and answer program. You ask
questions about the Bible. We give you
answers from the Bible. That's how it
works. We are so glad that you've joined
us this very day. My name is CA Murray.
To my right, Pastor Steven Boore. To my
left, Pastor David Salazar. Gentlemen,
it is always good to study the word of
God with you.
>> Amen.
>> We encourage you to send in your Bible
questions to us if you will. Write to TV
at sums as in marytv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org.
And we will get to your questions just
as soon as we possibly can. We make you
that guarantee that the answers will
come from the word of God. We encourage
you when you write your question, give
us your name. You can leave just your
first name if you wish, but let us know
where you're writing from. It helps us a
helps us to understand a little bit
about the footprint of the ministry and
the lives that we're touching around the
world. Pastor Salazar, would you ask
God's blessing upon this particular
sitting and then we'll go to our first
question.
>> Certainly. Let's let us pray. Heavenly
Father, we come before you at this hour
to humbly ask that you will give us the
direction of the Holy Spirit so that we
may be able to give answers according to
your word that are in harmony with your
will and that it may present the truth
to those who are watching that it may
encourage them and point them to Christ
to know you more and to have a closer
and growing relationship with you. We
thank you for your grace. We pray this
in Jesus name.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question comes
to us from now I'm saying gracious maybe
it's gracias.
[laughter]
So it's one of the two but thank you for
your question. I'd like to know what the
mark of the beast really is. There have
been rumors that microchips and other
biometric signals are the mark. I'd like
to know what the Bible and the spirit of
prophecy says. So thank you for your
question. I remember when do you you
guys remember when these um barcodes
came in originally back in the 60s and
70s people were saying that was the mark
of the beast and just about every time
something new technological comes out
that's the mark of the beast you know so
we need to understand first of all what
it is and what it is not um so who wants
to take that who wants to start out
>> well maybe I could just mention
something as we begin to answer this
question that is that there's a
difference between the mark of the beast
and the mechanism that is used to
enforce the mark of the beast.
>> Well said.
>> Um it very well might be that eventually
we will be in a cashless society. I'm
not predicting that. I'm not a prophet.
But it seems to me that be able to to be
able to control buying and selling there
has to be some control mechanism.
whether it be a microchip, whether it be
a a credit card, um something electronic
to be able to control buying and selling
uh in the US and eventually globally.
>> But that is not the mark of the beast.
That is the mechanism that will be used
to forbid buying and selling to those
who do not receive the mark of the
beast.
>> Very good. So there's a difference
between the mechanism
and what the mark of the beast actually
is. The way in which they're going to
enforce this enforce it and the mark
itself.
>> Yes. And I I would uh add the technology
already exists for the implanting of
chips. There are many things that people
are carrying around in their bodies that
have been implanted there uh through
medicine. So that it's not a leap of
faith to think that that could happen
because the technology exists for that.
Let's talk about Pastor David what the
beast is. Uh you want to wrestle with
that a little bit?
>> Yes. Um first of all, you know, what
does the Bible say the mark of the beast
is? Uh this actually comes or you know
we go to Revelation 13 and and uh
obviously we have here in the ministry a
lot of studies on revelation. Pastor Bor
has done an extensive series of of of of
studies on this concept and there are
many sermons that we can we encourage
our our audience to to look into. But uh
briefly, Revelation 13 describes in
verses 1-10 a beast power which is the
beast that raises from the sea. And this
particular beast is really u the
power that has become
or or was so strong for many many years.
It actually gives you a time frame when
it was supposed to rule over the world.
And just particularly this is speaking
of the power that the papacy had uh in
in May for 1260 years where they had
dominion through the civil powers of
Europe to control the conscience and to
enforce um the mandate of what the
papacy believed was their their their
authority. So uh basically that first
beast of revelation 13 is the papal
power the papacy that was controlling or
or or using again the connection to the
civil power to enforce its power. Now
this beast has receives
a a wound deadly wound and then another
beast rises from the earth which is uh
it's in verses 11 to 17. The second
beast is the one that eventually creates
the image of the beast so that they
those that worship the beast receives
their mark. This is very basically a
very brief analysis of this. Uh so this
second beast which is uh you know the
the United States of America will
enforce will raise up this third element
which the image of the beast that will
have or will implement the mark of the
beast. So we have to understand that the
main things is in regards to worship God
is not necessarily and is not just you
know economics or technology obviously
it's not it main thing is worship and
authority this is really what the mark
of the beast is about is who you worship
and whose authority you're under and so
um the key thing here is who you worship
and this is why verse 13 I mean in
revelation 13 uh we go there verse uh 16
it tells us there this uh power that
raises from the earth that creates the
image of the beast. He says he causes
all both and small and great rich and
poor free and slave to receive a mark on
their right hand or in their foreheads.
And this mark he says and that no one
verse 17 may not buy or sell except one
who has a mark or the name of the beast
or the number of his name. So here is
where we can see that receiving the mark
will have economical influence in your
in your life. If you don't accept the
mark of the beast, you will not be able
to buy or sell. You will not be able to
have financial freedom and that kind of
thing. So sometimes people emphasize
maybe what the economical thing will be
but they don't understand that that's
actually a result of receiving the mark
of the beast of receiving that you know
that that either in your mind by
believing or by force because it's
convenient for you. Um, briefly, um,
this right here is just letting us know
that in the last days, there will be
some sort of law that will enforce.
Who do you align yourself with? Who do
you worship? Who do you believe God's
way, you receive God's seal or if you
don't accept God's seal, you will accept
by default mark of the beast. You will
accept either by convenience or because
you believe a lie, you will accept the
mark of the beast. Now what the market
beast actually is, it's not other than
the day that that identifies the rule of
the papacy. The day that they say is a
sign of their power and that day is
Sunday. So Sunday observance right now
is not the mark of the beast because
it's not law. It's not established by
law. But the mark of this will become
Sunday law because when it becomes a law
when the world when this country
establishes a law of worshiping or you
know worship God only on Sunday then
that is the moment it actually becomes
the mark of the beast and and the Sunday
worship by by forced becomes that
element of mark of the beast. So that's
kind of the uh I don't know the nutshell
what the mark of the beast is and I have
some verses to show.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay. I want to go in and just fill in
some of the or expose some of the pylons
that Yeah.
>> that undergur your your understanding.
[clears throat] Uh and thank you for for
that.
>> Um when we talk about the mark of the
beast, beasts in general, um there are
beasts throughout the Bible, but in
apocalyptic literature, beasts have a
little different uh
facet that that that is exposed. Uh so
the book of Daniel, the book of re
revelation, beasts are different things.
In Daniel chapter 7:23, we get the
statement that beasts are kingdoms. It
can be a secular kingdom. It can be a
religious kingdom. So when we're talking
about beasts, we're talking about
kingdoms. So that lets out biometric
chips and chips and other kinds of
things. As you well said, that could be
the mechanism, but the beast itself is
an entity. Yeah.
>> That that we're dealing with.
>> Okay.
apocalyptic literature, beasts represent
kingdoms or other kinds of of of
entities. So, so we see that. So, when
you go to Revelation, you have you have
beasts, but they mean something else.
And of course, you've given us a very
good explanation of what of what that
means. Pastor, you want to weigh in on
this?
>> Okay. I want to recommend
a chapter in great controversy for uh
gracious
which will explain
>> the beast,
the image of the beast, the mark of the
beast, [laughter]
the lamb beast,
>> the two horns of the lamb beast. This is
a spectacular chapter in the book great
controversy. If you really want to
understand Revelation 13,
the name of the chapter is God's law
immutable.
It is a phenomenal chapter.
>> And um you know we need to understand
who the beast is before we can know what
the image of the beast is and what the
mark of the beast is.
>> So who is the beast? like you mentioned
the beast is that uh power that is
described in Revelation 13 1-10
>> which uh it says that it would speak
blasphemies against the most high that
it would trample on the saints of the
most high and it would rule for uh 42
months which is the same as time times
the dividing of time yes and 1260 years
>> so the papacy is the power that ruled
for 1260 years.
>> Mhm.
>> And received the deadly wound in 1798
when Pope Pas I 6 was taken prisoner and
he died prisoner in France.
>> Yeah.
>> That's the deadly wound which means that
this power was going to be out of
commission for a while because it had a
deadly wound. Now what is the image of
the beast? Well, the an image is similar
to what it is reflecting,
>> right? And so what was the main
characteristic of the beast? Because
this is the image of the beast. What is
the main characteristic of the beast?
The main characteristic is that it used
the power of the state to persecute
God's true people.
>> True.
>> It's a the church using the state
>> to persecute
>> to enforce its doctrines and its
practices.
>> So what would the image of the beast be?
The image of the beast would be a power
that uses the state to accomplish its
purposes.
>> Yeah.
>> And who makes that image? The image is
made by the beast that rises from the
earth.
>> Which represents the United States of
America. The two horns are civil and
religious liberty, church and state.
>> And that begins at verse 11.
>> Yeah. When you keep them separate,
>> the result is freedom.
>> Yes.
>> When you unite them, the result is
oppression. And so this beast from the
earth, the United States of America, is
going to make an image
of the first beast, which means that
it's going to unite church and state
>> like the papacy did in the past.
>> And the papacy is going to enforce the
the United States is going to enforce
the mark of the beast or the mark of the
papacy. Now, what does a papacy claim is
its mark?
It claims that it that it had the power
to change God's law
>> uh the Sabbath to Sunday.
>> Now, he would have to have the power of
God to do that. This system claims to be
God on earth.
>> Yeah.
>> And so therefore, the mark of the beast
is defined by the papacy itself. The
mark of the beast is the sign of the
power that it claims to change God's
law.
>> Right?
That's where Sunday comes in.
>> So, Sunday is technically will become
the mark of the beast like you mentioned
>> when the United States enforces the
papal Sabbath by law.
>> And then everybody has to decide. The
whole world is going to have an option
to decide for one or for the other. Uh
that hasn't come yet. There's a lot of
sincere Christians in all churches.
>> Uh they serve God the to the best of
their knowledge. their heart is with the
Lord.
>> But those people who are sincere
eventually when this crunch time comes,
>> yes,
>> they're going to leave Babylon and
they're going to join God's remnant
people and they will proclaim the
message to the world along with those
who are already members of the church.
So the what is the mark of the beast?
The mark of the beast is not microchips,
[laughter]
but the microchips might be used to
enforce the mark of the beast.
>> And probably this will be done digitally
uh when there's no longer currency. M
>> you know what'll happen is if you know
if you're uh working a job uh what
they'll do is they'll just transfer your
salary on a weekly or monthly basis to
your account
>> and you're going to have to show ID or
somehow
>> so that you can buy and sell. Uh so
basically in a nutshell the mark of the
beast will become the mark of the beast
when it's enforced by the United States
on pain of not being able to buy or sell
and eventually on pain of death.
>> Well said. You know I just want to give
some some some color or some outline to
this. You're talking about changing uh
times and and laws. One of the things of
the Protestant Reformation was of course
the Bible and the Bible only solos tour.
Um in that very long extended meeting of
bishops called the council of Trent uh
towards the end in the last couple of
meetings uh Archbishop Gonzaga uh by
University who became the Archbishop of
Reio came up with a a a statement that
was adopted. He called it the Protestant
inconsistency.
>> He said, "You you guys say that you're
the Bible and the Bible only."
>> But you keep Sunday.
>> That's our day.
>> We did that.
>> Yep.
>> So, you are inconsistent.
>> And that that argument has been used
more or less by by Catholic scholars
down through the years to say, "You're
really just a strange brother. you're
Catholic because we bet we we endorse
that day and you co-sign the day. So
you're you're you call yourselves
Protestant, but you're not. You're
you're really Catholic. So um I think
it's important what you mentioned that
there's going to come this coercive
aspect. So when you hear about calls for
keeping Sunday and maybe voting that we
should all keep Sunday or voting that we
should all rest on Sunday, that same
coercion that was used during the middle
ages during the ascendancy of the church
is going to be revisited in these last
days. You know, there was a statement
that was written by John O'Brien, who
for many years was u a teacher, a
theology professor at Notre Dame
University
>> in Indiana.
>> And basically he did the same thing. He
challenged Protestants. You claim to go
by the Bible only and not by tradition.
>> So why do you keep Sunday if there's no
place in the Bible that says that Sunday
is the new day of worship?
>> Yes. He says it's because you accept
without wanting to real without want to
to accept it uh the tradition of the
Roman Catholic Church. You're accepting
the authority of the Catholic Church.
And then and then he uses a very
interesting metaphor.
>> He says it's like a child
>> fleeing from home
>> but carrying in his pocket
a lack of his mother's hair. Mhm.
>> In other words, the the reason why
Protestantism is going to return to the
mother is because it never was able to
totally sever its relationship with the
mother. Protestants still believe that
when a person dies, they go to hell
>> if they were wicked and they their soul
goes to heaven if they were righteous.
They still believe that the soul of man
is immortal. They still believe that
Sunday is the day of rest. In other
words, they have doctrines in common
with the Roman Catholic Church and
therefore eventually they're going to
set aside the doctrines that are
conflictive
>> and they're going to be on the same page
>> and and you know there is um she asked
this question also gracious about you
know spirit prophecy you mentioned
pastor that wonderful chapter and great
controversy uh but you know I want to
share just just a quick quote from
spirit prophecy
uh Testimonies to the church volume 8
page 117. And we have to remember that
the reason why Sunday is going to become
that market beast. Why Sunday? Why not
something else? Well, because it's the
way in which the enemy Satan has
deceived uh so many Christians, some of
them very, you know, genuine Christians.
And they don't understand that by
aligning themselves with worship on
Sunday, they
separate themselves from becoming truly
the people of God. I'm going to read to
you this uh and she actually quotes uh
Exodus 31:12 and 13. Notice what she
says. This is again testimonies for the
church volume 8 page 117. She says, "The
sign or seal of God is revealed in the
observance of the seven-day Sabbath, the
Lord's memorial of creation." The Lord
spoke unto him also, saying, "Speak thou
also unto the children of Israel,
saying, Verily, my Sabbaths you shall
keep, for it is a sign between me and
you throughout your generations, that ye
may know that I am the Lord that doth
sanctified you." Here she says, the
Sabbath is clearly designed as a sign
between God and his people. The mark of
the beast is the opposite of this. The
observance of the first day of the week.
This mark distinguishes those who
acknowledge the supremacy of the papal
authority from those who acknowledge the
authority of God. So as you well said
pastor you know unfortunately many
Christians who are going to embrace to
the knowledge of or to the to the
tradition of Sunday are going to do so
mainly not because it's biblical not
because it's in any way changed by God
but because they rather accept the
authority of pap of the papal you know
church or the papacy over God's clear
word of God and you know and so this is
where we have to remember that the mark
of the beast is going to become that
final test that opportunity between
choosing following the God's word or
following tradition of men and thus it's
going to be the final test till today
still is not that final test because the
world has not yet known this but as it
becomes that day of of um you know
global
separation of of day that maybe the
world's going to come together and we
are seeing already this happening in
amazingly you know there's calls of this
in this country it's time to go back to
you know having a day in our
constitution to serve God and that kind
of thing they're speaking of Sunday
unfortunately but that's what they're
going to do they're going to to do that
eventually and so we have to remember
that that is going to be the test of
faith of whether we believe God and
believe his authority or accept the
man's authority
>> you know it's very very important to
realize iz.
>> Mhm.
>> That the last test is going to be just
like the first test.
>> Thank you.
>> Mhm.
>> What was the first test? It was over a
tree.
>> Mhm.
>> But behind the tree
>> is whose word are you going to obey?
>> Mhm.
>> Whose authority are you going to follow?
>> Yeah.
>> Are you going to listen to God
>> who says don't eat from the tree or are
you going to listen from the devil who
says eat from the tree?
So the test the testing mechanism if you
please
>> is the tree
>> which by the way is in the middle of the
garden
>> and there's a positive and negative
command of God. He says you can eat from
all of them but not from one.
>> Mhm.
>> Which commandment is in the middle of
God's law?
>> Fourth.
>> The fourth commandment. Does the fourth
commandment have a positive uh command?
Yeah. You can eat you you can take all
six days for yourself
>> to work. But the seventh day is the
Sabbath.
>> Yes.
>> And what is the test at the end of time?
The test is not going to be a tree.
>> It's going to be a day.
>> Well, I was once talking to someone who
was a Sunday keeper and you know, he was
being critical of the Sabbath and I said
I said, you know, um you say that why
how why would God test the whole world
with a with a day? I said, well, he
tested Adam with a tree.
>> With a tree,
>> you know, but the issue behind it is the
same.
>> Yeah. The issue is who you will obey.
And Revelation 12 uh verse 17 says that
there will be a group who keep the
commandments of God.
>> Uh and they will be faithful even in the
face of death. They're going to say, "We
are not going to give in because we
choose to serve God instead of man."
>> Yes.
>> Say what you want about the alleged
sanctity of Sunday over Sabbath.
The bottom line is one day is biblical.
the other day is not biblical. You can
pull up all kind of rational
arguments to for Sunday,
>> but the one thing you cannot say is that
it's in the Bible.
>> Yeah.
>> It is it is not
>> right.
>> And if if you're a Christian, it's
what's in the Bible that is your
foundation. And Sunday simply is not
there.
>> Yeah.
>> It is not there.
>> They pile a whole bunch of
misinterpreted texts that try and prove
it. You know the Paul Paul says I just
be persuaded in your own mind but but
the word Sabbath isn't even there
>> right
>> uh so anyway uh I hope that this has
been helpful.
>> Yeah, this was a very good question.
Gracious uh we thank you so very much
for it. Uh gentlemen, our time again has
slipped into eternity. It gets away from
us so fast. In closing, we wish you
grace and peace through our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ. We'll see you again
soon. Bye-bye and God bless.